this is an Entertainment Tonight  exclusive what's happening we'll be  opening up for Beyonce on the formation  tour in Europe so we're so excited  excited so much fun so you're gonna open  up for her all throughout Europe would I  mean how amazing is that  oh we just found out like a week ago we  were so excited  she is just in such an amazing person  inside and out you know being around her  is just amazing because she's like just  such a teacher to us especially as young  girls who are coming up in this music  industry it's just so amazing  what was your reaction when you found  out you've been working so hard and we  can't wait to go on tour with her  congratulations